hello internet and welcome to yet
another episode of game on I am Todd
Kerpelman I'm a developer advocate here
on the Play Games team hey I'm Duncan
Curtis I'm a product manager on the
Google Play team and I've just launched
the google play games out oh well that's
very convenient because that happens to
bring us to this week's episode episode
6 we're going to be talking about the
play games app before we get into that
though let's talk about some other news
and updates the first thing is that some
of you might have noticed there is a new
update to play services that is been
rolling out and I think by the time this
video launches it should be out to all
of the world what's new for you on the
Play game services side of things not
much it's so it's not a very exciting
announcement but we did introduce a
number of bug fixes a lot in real-time
multiplayer and there's been this image
loader crash that I know has been
driving people crazy over on the public
bug database so that has finally been
addressed thanks everyone for your
patience and by the way proof that the
public bug database actually works that
that's how we caught this one so
remember visit that and what will add on
a link here and report any issues that
you find cuz um apparently it works in
addition if you can't get enough of me
if you're saying once every two weeks is
just not enough Todd I have started a
new dev bite series which is introducing
play games for iOS it's a series of
screencasts where we're going to go
through adding sign-in achievements
leaderboards some sharing on on Google+
to an iOS application so go ahead and
follow along or share it with your
favorite iOS developer are you saying
this like now with a hundred percent
mode one hundred percent more tile
that's fantastic it's actually like it's
gonna be like six hundred percent more
time use as well three times a week
insistent this is news it's honestly
more Todd than most of you really want
so I won't be offended if that it's
that's too much Todd anyway we should go
on to our main topic here which is the
play games app
yes Duncan you've been in charge of this
thing now I know we just launched a
release is there anything exciting in
this this week's release yes actually
we've got some really cool stuff so
first I'll discuss a little bit about
the app and then I'll maybe go through
and talk about some of the some of the
things that have updated okay you all
know that the play games app it's the
hub of gaming for Android as it grows
and more features are rolling out it's
becoming the place you go when you want
to do gaming on Android and that's good
for developers because now we've got a
place for everyone to go not just a
vertical in the store we've now got our
own app it also lets people game with
each other find each other track their
progress in your games your games where
you mark your own achievements and let
people update them and you get to they
get to track their progress and also
discover new titles discover some of
your titles discover what their friends
are playing maybe they're friends are
playing your game now so I think perhaps
it's best if I show you that'd be good
let's uh let's go to a demo cool so
here's the home screen of the
destination app as everyone knows and
loves it we got the my game section at
the top which shows all your play
enabled games so now are these all games
that you have installed in the device no
it's where it's whatever you played most
recently on play on the Play enable
games so you could have been playing at
you know just a hug back to your
deadline series you could have been
playing a play enabled game on iOS and
it may still it will still show up here
gotcha okay so this is basically this
list is populated based on the most
recent games i've been playing using the
the play game service correct okay it
also has it shows you for the users it
shows the number of achievements they've
got to sort of drive people who really
love to get that your hundred-percent
achievement complete on a game you know
if they can see here that you've got
your 28 of 29 achievements very likely
to jump back into your game even if it's
down in the fourth or fifth slot okay
next we have the player section these
are all of your G+ friends who are plain
abled so people who are actually gaming
have been gaming recently gotcha so this
is people in my Google+ circles who have
used a game using Play services so
basically we know hey these guys have
signed into a game they're their gaming
they're probably people you could play a
multiplayer game way exactly as you can
see here here's a la paz and she's been
playing aw fantastic sample app
nostalgic racer so if I jump on in how
did you know she was playing nostalgic
racer so if I jump back up for once I
can see in the bottom right hand corner
is that little icon little icons yeah so
it's really great because if if you're a
big fan of nostalgic racers I clearly AM
and say for example Triple Town share
that this bright folks great game so if
you're a fan of one of these games it
makes you much more likely to be like
hey I should go check out other games
that this friend has been playing so go
I'll dive into there a little bit more
deeply in a minute okay here we have our
featured games so this is where we're
showing the list of featured titles that
are playin abled now we have just
released one update here as well which
I'll point out is that installed or
purchase titles will no longer show up
in this list if there's more featured
games for you to show gotcha so if i
already had monster shooter too it was
no longer show up in this road unless
you had all of our featured games which
is a happy problem okay what that really
means is that if you do for developers
specifically for developers are going to
be really important because if you do
make our featured list then it doesn't
matter if you're number one in the
featured list you still have a really
great chance of getting high levels of
visibility in the play games app so now
how do i how do I get on this featured
games list featured games this is a hand
curated list by BD team okay so I gotta
make a game that impresses our BD team
exactly we're going to probably enable
game services you would that's a minimum
requirement okay and I'm assuming this
list is this a completely separate list
than say some of the featured lists in
the Play Store correct bats Craig does a
completely separate list
that we take care of okay because we're
gamers we know what we want and you know
we like we like really great
integrations so there's some really good
example integrations if you check out
our dev docs for great ways to integrate
our service you know there's there's
basic ways to do it and then there's
really cool and impressive ways to do it
so we're always looking for that in your
day to be great situation so these tend
to be good games that also have really
nice integration yes it certainly makes
it more common okay yeah keep going so
the other list is you may know so you
may know is a place for you to find
people that Google+ back end has said
hey these are people you not so good
place for you to find most likely find
your friends got so now are these people
already in my circles these are people
not my circle people in your circle so
good+ things I probably know them you
probably know them there's probably a
good chance and are these people
necessarily gamers not at this stage
okay yeah okay however you're probably
going to know which one of you which
ones of your friends our game is anyway
gotcha yeah so one of the other updates
we've just recently one of the other
updates we recently released is that
some of these some of these rows for
players and for you may know when you
jump into a next level down so for
example if I jump into a player and jump
back up if I had more than three players
here if I had more than the maximum row
number we would actually cycle between
some of the players so that you can see
a bit more what your friends are doing
that also apply so you may know row is
that we want to really just filter
through that list a little more quickly
and let you get a chance to see some
more be a right that this looks
different than it is different from last
time Wow magic yeah so you know just
minor minor tweaks insurance here here
and there I did want to jump in and just
show you a little bit of the cool thing
a cool thing with places we mentioned
earlier that SE le had been playing the
style to grace earn as I love it I would
like to see what else Elly is playing
here I can see all the other games that
all the other play enable games that
Ellie is been playing and I can jump
straight into one like Triple Town like
wow here's a little bit about Triple
Town here's the game features that it
uses as
see there at the top it uses
achievements and leaderboards and since
I haven't got the game installed yet I
haven't gotten any achievements but I
can check the achievements out before I
even own the game so this is a good
point for developers that are a good
reason for developers to implement
really great art and useful text can be
explained to use this quite easily that
I can see if there's interesting things
here to do okay now I noticed you got
here by going through Ellie's profile
yeah can I see Ellie's achievements not
yet okay it's not yet meaning that it's
a good idea and maybe just you it is a
fantastic idea all right that's what I
want to hear let's go back to the About
section for one second so where does
this information come from where do we
get these badges is that automatic
where's this description so the badge
badging features come from when you
enable your game in the dev console you
get to say hey these are the features
i'm using we have some smarts on the
backend that determine legitimate use of
the service okay and if that passes then
your badging will show up both here and
in the Play Store okay so that's
basically I know Triple Town is gone and
they've added achievements and they
obviously have leaderboards and so our
system is basically detected that and
they sort of get the badges automatic
right there's nothing additional the
developer needs time you there are bits
you know your corrected that as soon as
they start sending us the signals and
have everything enabled in the dev
console it just works ok the description
is being pulled from the Play Store and
we're looking at updating some some
features in the future to make this more
interactive more interesting but square
up at the moment wait is it actually
from the Play Store or is it from the
developer console oh sorry I was from
the developer guy we just did the update
you got me well played thanks um yeah we
actually enclosing you're too we just
recently released an update to the dev
console where you'll be able to do some
copying and pasting automatically Wow
nice ok so from here users can jump into
the play store to purchase or they can
just launch the game in the top right
where it's got free there over here oh
so clicking on that will take me to the
Play Store but now we will take you to
the play store where you can install and
then if you have this install from here
you can just click play straight from
that gotcha you say for now meaning that
you've got other ideas maybe in the
future for what that button could do
goes to the Play Store hey I'm going to
get you to commit to some future feature
at some point yeah so we talked about
achievements I'd like to talk about
leaderboards a little bit as well so
just for developers to know you can have
more than one leaderboard so you can
have your high score which can be let's
say it was a high school you can have as
you can see here you can have week daily
weekly or all-time leader boards that's
up to the user to take a look at but you
can also have multiple leaderboards so
for a car racing game this could be
drift versus drag racing versus and a
carjacking if you're in GTA or something
but this is this is the ability for
people to compete in multiple different
ways how they want to compete ok so here
within here you can see people within
your the sorry the play can see within
people within their circles that have
been competing and also the entire
public leaderboard so this gives me a
chance to compete in multiple different
ways within your game so integrate
leaderboards all right that sound sounds
good and so I was going to say I mean we
provide the ability for developers to
show leaderboards in their games already
but I suppose the advantage here is I
don't need to go and install the game
before I sort of get to see the
leaderboard correct so you can go check
out the leader board of any game so I
don't even have Triple Town installed on
this account trust me I have no other
counts yeah but you can go check it out
and see what's it you know what's a good
score you also get an idea that if you a
friend of yours are you bragging about
you know getting two million in Triple
Town you go to the leader boy you're
like but 28 million is what the top guy
has then you know you can quickly get a
feel for how your friend how your friend
is doing ok I would like to point out
that you mentioned something interesting
about the leaderboards and achievements
the developers can implement it can use
our api's and implement whatever user
interface they want in their game if
they choose we do provide client you I
so that so that everyone has a basic
experience and it's really quick to get
up and going but irrespective of the way
you implement implement them your side
up here in the destination app and the
play games app like this so that way
there's a consistent experience for
users in the gaming hub I think that's
about all I really wanted to talk about
for the moment I'm really happy with
this might with this minor update we had
some bug fixes which is nice little bit
more stability the changes a little bit
more flow through of the players in the
different cards so you can see more and
we've got lots more exciting things to
come all right well that sounds good all
right well then maybe let's just jump
into some some follow-up QA starting
with so you know where is this app how
do I get it you can get it on the place
tool if you look for play games you can
get it there and some devices come with
a pre-installed do you know which ones
it's ever increase it okay I do know
that right now if you get the new Nexus
7 it comes with that install an extra
seven give does okay so Nexus 7 and so
the people that are using the play games
app right now are people that have
actually gone out and said I want to
install this app and so they're they're
probably a good audience yeah they're
great orange we're going to really
engaged audience with really good
retention and so getting your gaming now
in the early stages as this app is is
taking off it's a really great way to
get to find those dedicated gamers
there's not as many games as we want yet
using our services I mean we still got a
massive slew of them and it's been
fantastic Thank You developers for in so
many of you integrating but not
everyone's done it yet so it's a it's a
really great opportunity for some of the
indie devs to to come on integrate our
services have a great integration and be
able to get featured or have have it go
through the system like a wildfire in
these early stages okay get well I this
kind of you sort of answer your second
question but yeah I mean I'm a developer
yeah what do I get for kind of why do I
care about this app yep well this comes
for free so if you integrate a Play game
services you get shown up here for free
so people will be able to search for
your game in the future we have as you
can see
let me just go down could we just switch
back to the demo for one second all
right we're there so popular is actually
a list of all our most popular playing
abled games so this is a similar to on
the Play Store where there's a that you
know so the top top free hilltop pay
games these are the top play enabled
games so if you're a developer you care
because if you integrate you can get
straight on this list and I guarantee
you we check this list very regularly
okay so if I click on one of these are
am I able to find out like say temple
run 2 which of my friends are playing
this not yet not yet yep that is there's
that there's that word again yet all
right and then I noticed you also have a
list for a popular multiplayer yes so we
have got a list of popular I haven't
seen that before you haven't seen it
before well I guess I should you should
probably take a look I could try this
app or something you should really try
this out so basically that way we're
rolling out different ways for users to
find your game by the way do they use
our services we have popular multiplayer
for now but you can only imagine that we
would want to do other things in the
future okay remember them yet got this
might be a very useful this might be
very useful instance where I might want
to see which of my friends are playing
this popular multiplayer exactly if you
want to jump in and see who's playing
super stickman golf right now you can
jump in and if I did have any friends
playing it would show up there's next up
in the future mucho if there's an extra
tab that would be awesome I can't wait
for for that which you're you're
launching next week is that right o.o
clearly hi thanks we invest one just
having rolled out of release all right
that was sarcasm for those of you not in
product development alright cool so so
it seems like you know there's there are
kind of various avenues to kind of
getting my game either sort of
discovered or you know rediscovered what
what seems to be the most popular is
that people look at the games they've
recently played they're like oh yeah I
remember playing that yesterday is it
the tortured stuff is it the haters my
friends are playing reengagement is
really
good so we find people open open the app
and like oh yeah I'm they couldn't see
the games they've been playing recently
if they're not feeling like playing that
one game they've been playing the most
recent it's a really great way to
reengage as i said before like those
achievements if you've got 28 of 29
achievements great reason to jump back
in and finish that last one off mm-hmm
it's also about discovery discovery has
been really good for us and featuring is
obviously sort of a really really great
way to get that ok what are what are
other ways I can sort of maximize my
discovery potential like you know
besides syrup getting featured which is
nice but it's uh yep the more services
you integrate the better so we have so
there are different ways to get
discovered four different services so
for example the multiplayer is a unique
unique service at the moment that has
its own entire tab okay and if we go
into let's go into one of these games
again is there anything you recommend in
terms of in terms of description that
maybe I could do to improve the
experience or is it kind of the same
guidelines as the Play Store it's the
same guidelines is the Play Store and
will be improving this in the future to
give you more ways to do it but once
again I would say try to have really
good achievement on and leaderboard on
so you can see here that while the
developer hasn't chosen to specify icons
if we jump back up to Triple Town which
I went through illy defined we have
individual icons for each leaderboard
yeah I've seen these look more appealing
yeah all right so maybe that's a that's
good advice to developers is uh because
I suppose if I'm a developer and you
know I'm a big developer and I'm
implementing my own leaderboard you I I
might not think that adding leaderboard
icons important because I'm like I don't
use it it's not you know that's not how
I'm doing in my game but it's still
going to show up here that's right so
I'd advise who have whatever developer
you are go check your Gangnam in the
in the play games app if you've already
launched alright that sounds good is
there a way for me to preview my game
and the play games app before I've
launched not yet not yet Japanese keeps
using that word yeah is it really just
cuz you don't want to say no and you
think that that son I was in there no
put their old great features I mean
these are definitely you know they're
all great features so all right well
that sounds good all right so developers
go if you've launched your game check it
out in the play games app make sure it
looks good make sure it looks like
something people be interested in
playing and and I guess let us know if
you have suggestions I think we might
even have an entry in the public bug
database for the play games destination
app so that any enhancements or any
requests or all those things that I just
mentioned go ahead and add them so we'll
add some peer pressure and for you to
get Duncan and his team to to add some
more stuff Thanks alright well I think
that wraps it up for this this week's
this by weeklies episode of game on
Thank You Duncan for coming out and
explaining everything to us about
thankfully games that thanks for having
me talk you're going to come back when
there's a new exciting announcement too
you'll see me back regular alright
excellent i can't wait thank you very
much YouTube audience and we will see
you in a couple of weeks